après oui je te dis si tu étais un
défaut du srec elle défaut la différence
si tu étais une injure allez vous faire
si tu étais une maladie
pire que le sida est ce possible
d'ailleurs au fait c'est parce que c'est
à cause du sida tu crois qu'elle se
refuse à lui
rennes de l'homme sait bien qu'il ya une
sorte de peur je dire ah ouais à qui
redistribue tout les cas et que ça va
être très intéressant pour les vrais
professionnels de jouer de cette peur
ambiante
si tu es tellement de thé vampires nous
voterons valls il était un microbe
celui de la lyre un insecte un siècle
scarabée immortel un reptile
le serpent de la genèse c'était un vis à
vis la notion même de vie si tu étais un
supplice un supplice toujours la chose
privée qui m'expliquent ce serait donc à
laquelle personne
un supplice auquel personne n'aurait pas
un supplice intime un supplice moral
moral si tu étais un supplice tu seras
un supplice sur la supplique morale qui
va réseau font des choses et un accident
la visite dans
la vie est un accident constant